welcome to this blitz game playing max
power from Denmark now we have three
games played against ammonia it feels
like it should have been more thought I
played more but ok let's see the two one
in my favor by the way so the Slav
fairly solid set up here with the queen
bee three plate this quite often
recently trying to limit blacks options
now if Ivan cd5 are not so easily
playable here black can play for see 5
or e 5 maybe needs to prepare that
Quincy seven maybe in 10-degree 51 idea
cable just keep it simple not to think
too much yeah but this allows 94 mm not
that great ok maybe night to d2 you can
take on the to Bishop takes and maybe
even take on be to know but then I have
fon would be one now it is probably good
for me so maybe this is an idea and
tending Knight to c4 if he does not take
and if he takes Bishop takes it has
helped my development quite a bit if he
takes on b2 I go we form the ship back
route be one rupee 7 now it should be
good yeah it should be good so I guess
he cannot take on p2 and my next move
will be my next moves will be e foreign
bit should be three possibly getting the
full center set up yeah that looks ok
okay i will look that move completely
Roxy one Roxy one queen bee to Bishop
you one wins wins the piece so I cannot
take on be too probably he just wanted
to misplace my Ruca bed yeah interesting
so what am i doing now what about night
a form it's the smooth evil toggle efore
he might take take on deform it looks
risky but maybe this is also an
interesting way to play I'm not sure it
probably will go to see seven other
squares look weird maybe to the aid my
idea was to continue with B form before
a 95 my problem maybe has a 5
may be interesting I was thinking really
before before 95 but before we five look
sir looks okay I guess well night
probably okay so should I go back to the
e for Plan B for Knight f6 maybe hmm it
takes e4 and deform now can prolly this
is the only continuation that fits with
night a form
so if I have what am I going to do
against you five am I just taking or
okay he's not going for that
surprisingly so maybe just be sure see 3
yeah let's do that fight against a five
so I can take be seven or not why why
not don't see why not okay let's take it
yeah but I thought 95 should still be
quite okay any better move I don't think
so so can you take before at all rook
could be three queen 85 this kind of
stuff or whoopsie one maybe looks you on
doubling against the week pawn and then
tending a night retreat after which the
point is almost falling if not falling
directly rupee three Queen 85 I don't I
didn't see if this should lead to
anything maybe maybe I still should have
considered it but now look b3 Queen a 5
97 wins the exchange I guess I guess
why does he have some technical trick
something Bishop c5 here sacrificing the
Queen yeah something like that is
probably probably the best chance okay
if I take it and just take c6 I guess
with the ruku yeah okay it's still some
some technical task it's not not totally
easy yeah but ok it should that should
should really be enough something that
gets the the porn rolling the deep horn
rolling efore n t5 before you will take
ok I don't want to be in any any pin you
for and d5
trying to win some space yeah h3g form
this kind of thing
time warning
check rook da da but I can I can also
give the check here f5 is not possible
but not necessary i want to play Bishop
before him getting getting rid of this
should be helpful check
if it takes I have the D poem free to go
yeah otherwise he will get get a
weakness on e cig so it should be quite
good so probably here and then push push
the pawns
kingi form and then both pawns will
start to go check
Joe that looks like made coming
checkmate okay so it was a was a nice
that I got got this rook be three in at
the right moment around here um I wasn't
quite sure what you should do I thought
he five he should go if I I believe but
he didn't go for that hmm it's
interesting the the engine stockfish
points out b5 here which I didn't
consider that much but it's interesting
now this is just it's quite logical you
playing against this seems to be seems
to be quite good for wide here I even
have queen bee seven interesting so we
went here and be five again was
interesting but I was I was a bit
concerned about 85 so I've prevented
that it still keeps an edge I think
around here it's not not very nice takes
takes rook c3 queen bee 695 queen here
okay so I interesting that was also a
good alternative instead of this to play
play this I didn't think about that very
much but it's interesting the idea is
that after this if the rook moves and it
yeah if it sure if it wants to be saved
and not must move and then this is
strong this threatens not g6 with Jack
destruction of the Kings side porn
structure and 96 poets very good it's
better than my move it keeps a big edge
but still owe me I but here this is a
mrs. winning now because here I'm just
winning a big exchange and in the in the
game continuation I was winning the
Queen and I I don't think I I slipped up
chat him always kept control it's it's
the way to go try to avoid any counter
play
and just push the pawns forward in a in
a be a sort of coordinated way ok I hope
you enjoyed this thanks for watching